[Music]
hey
we're back i'm not even hungover because
i didn't even get drunk last night
because i had to be on another show
i guess zack is not here but he said i
think he said he listened to it i
thought
hey i thought um i thought b's next name
was keith libby
i thought that's what the message said
that i got yeah
yeah i sent it to keith libby i hope
it's the same one
says tom what's your facebook name
you're just thomas thomas ross
you see me yeah right there he's not
hiding yeah
he's not hiding he
so you know yeah hopefully uh you guys
had a
oh louis said i heard your show jenny it
was real good oh thanks i was super
nervous i
really don't like doing live radio but
you know at least they couldn't see me
i don't know why more people listening
to uh our streams than listen to [ __ ]
live radio
i guess that is dead as [ __ ] now well
the thing about it is that whenever i do
a show like that it's usually about
i'm usually talking about faceless
villain and so i'm always kind of afraid
that i'm going to forget like all the
details because i always have to like
take these copious notes from my book
and
read [ __ ] out of it and everything like
that and it's just kind of like i don't
know
so for some reason that's a lot more
nerve-wracking than than this
is you know what i mean yeah because
here it's like we have the same people
listening
so they're a lot more forgiving if i
[ __ ] something up that one i just kind
of feel like
it was it wasn't um bad though and like
i said it was kind of like i only had to
talk in like 20 minute chunks because
they did like
you know news and commercials and all
this other kind of stuff so it was kind
of like
i didn't feel too bad about it but um
yeah i think um
i think zach told me he listened to it
as well i still can't believe we did it
we did a four hour show
and then i did another two hour show
like later on man i was so tired
he says that is him but he doesn't see a
message dude i got i sent it right here
maybe it's in maybe it's in that thing
where
because isn't there's messages and then
if you're not
friends with that person then it sends
it to this other folder like
message requests no actually actually
we're friends on facebook
oh okay maybe you just don't know how it
works okay
yeah maybe no one knows how it works
facebook is not working yeah
i just sent you another one yeah yep
but holy crap you guys we had i woke up
well it didn't wake you up i don't know
how
but um because you know how yesterday we
were talking about we had all the
tornado warnings and [ __ ]
yeah last night it was like i think it
was five something in the morning
and i woke up and it was just this
horrible horrible storm
and i just left right through it yeah
and i was kind of like holy [ __ ] man i
thought like the [ __ ] roof was going
to blow off
and then it kind of passed over and i
was like okay fine and like i got up to
go to the bathroom or whatever and i got
back in bed and little pooky was laying
there with her big old eyes going oh
[ __ ]
and um then i woke up again at like 6 30
and it was doing it again like worse
than the first time
i mean the rain was like [ __ ]
horizontal like against the windows and
it was like
and like the whole time i'm sitting
there thinking oh man this better not be
a tornado better
be a tornado i kept i kept listening for
a sound like a freight train because
that's what they always say
you know how you hear when i'm [ __ ]
all right
i'm gonna have to get keep [ __ ]
settled here man
[Laughter]
sent you a message bro lots of uh oh
louis said the atlanta ripper segment
was real good thank you very much
uh yeah i talked about atlanta ripper i
talked about touring room 1046
talked about the frog boys see look i
sent that to you look
there's there's your little chip
[Laughter]
there's your little [ __ ] yeah i can't
see it it's blurry
all right hold on let me see what are
you what are you even doing
what are you even doing hold on
i'm showing a profile
showing the profile that's the profile
all right if that's not you then that's
the fake you
okay
it's on messenger
you guys need to sort this [ __ ] out yeah
but yeah the 13 o'clock
uh facebook page generally i
i answer that because that's kind of
that's an offshoot of my
that's one of my pages an offshoot of my
group i have so many [ __ ] pages i
have 13 o'clock one i have a faceless
villain one i have a
author one i have what else
i think i have one for
my games i don't even remember i have a
bunch i don't even use anymore too
he's probably got me muted
[Laughter]
he's not muted or anything i [ __ ] you
know he's just right there
okay business says okay that's my old
account yeah be right back it's in my
other phone
okay you guys will get this sorted out
can we talk about oculus now yeah okay
so
uh yeah so this is usually a little bit
older movie than we would normally do on
matinee
but one of our lovely people
sent us a blu-ray of it and i was very
excited about it i had seen it like a
few years ago
um obviously directed by mike flanagan
who
you know very famously did dr sleep like
you know uh
gerald's game uh haunting of hill house
hunting a blind manor
this is actually his second uh
full-length feature film first one being
absentia
which actually if you haven't seen that
that is also very good it is
like micro budget but it just goes to
show
what somebody as talented as mike
flanagan
can do with nothing money um
absentia is actually on
to be for free okay oculus might be as
well i'm not real sure but i know for
sure that absentia is on there because i
just saw it like five minutes ago
um and i would recommend that as well so
if you're really into mike flanagan
stuff you can kind of see
he had made some short films prior to
that one but
um you can really see like the emergence
of like this great [ __ ]
talent coming out and um yeah so then
oculus was his second one now oculus was
like
it was based on a short film that he had
made
and they were talking about you know
maybe doing a full length
but i think that when the production
company
kind of was going to give him the money
to do it they said we'll give you the
money do it
if you make it found footage and he to
his credit said
absolutely [ __ ] not yeah
so then finally he talked to them into
like not doing it found footage and i
think that's really
really good because actually this movie
you had never seen this
no it was a good movie though i liked it
i mean like i said you can really tell
it had a slow start but once you started
rolling i was like going yeah this is
pretty good
it the ending was [ __ ] up
and not i didn't really think it was
that satisfying it's not kind of the
ending i put on it
but i respect his choice i mean it was
just that was his choice of how he's
going to end that movie
well it was kind of a bleak ass and yeah
that's what i was thinking and i mean
well
i kind of like that about it though i
kind of would have
had them win against against the mirror
but no they lose
just saying don't really spoil anything
well this came out in 2013. yeah
they they makes it scarier because
the mirror all through the whole entire
i mean if you guys have not seen oculus
obviously it's about
a haunted or a cursed mirror i like
another thing too i like that he doesn't
really explain how the mirror got that
way or why it's evil how it's able to
manipulate people's
uh realities and their thoughts and
their behavior and stuff
um and he deliberately left it like that
he said i'm really into like love crafty
and [ __ ] where it's just like evil
and it's not explained it's just here's
an evil thing you know you gotta deal
with it
but the thing about the mirror the lasso
glass
is that it just is and it does these
horrible things
and you can't win against it i think
that was what made this movie so scary
for me was that the
kaylee character um you know when in the
present because like i said this kind of
runs parallel
present and past like them as kids and
them as adults
and her whole thing is you know i want
to kill this mirror and she's obviously
spent years
researching the history of it and she
kind of has this whole elaborate thing
set up to destroy it and
she's not dumb about it like she's
obviously put a lot of thought into it
she's rigged up like all these traps and
all this cameras and stuff
but the fact that she is really smart
about it and did put all this time into
it
into destroying it but it was still too
smart for her it was still too evil for
her she couldn't defeat it
you know what i mean so to me that made
it like a lot scarier
because if you could just like bust it
at the end
you know it would just be like not as
scary i don't think
but i think that makes it a lot scarier
because it was just kind of like this
[ __ ]
and i think that is probably my favorite
part of this movie i really really like
horror movies that kind of [ __ ] with
your
[Music]
sense of reality and i like that the
mirror
that's kind of its superpower you know
what i mean and it's like so
you know the movie it's like real
disorienting
because you never know if what the
mirror is showing you
is what's really happening and the
mirror can make you think
that you're doing one thing when
actually you're doing something else
it's like hey i went outside and i
called the police on my cell phone but
it was like someone else's voice
it's like i didn't really go out there
and call really i was standing here in
front of the mirror
and it's like that to me is like a
really really cool
concept you know what i mean and um
i also really like the ghosts in this
like i thought they were because
i feel like he did he does kind of like
a similar look because i guess
you know the ghost and haunting of hill
house looked a little bit like this as
well
but i liked in this one that the eyes of
all the ghosts were like
reflective like mirror you know like
mirrors in their eyeballs
and i thought that was like really
really creepy and um
just i don't know it's just it's just
such a great
idea and i just really really like the
way it was done and there wasn't a lot
of
it wasn't super gory but then some of
the gore
was real like skin crawly like you know
what i mean like when he was
putting the um that staple remover thing
like into his
[ __ ] fingernail and [ __ ] like that
like when she was eating the light bulb
like thinking it was the apple and stuff
like that
so it just kind of goes to show that
they don't you don't have to have
all this over-the-top gore to just kind
of like creep people out
um and you know it's just really well
done and i think that
you can really see a lot of the traits
that have made mike flanagan
so well regarded in the horror genre
i mean pretty much fully formed right
here in this movie and even in absentia
which is like his first one
and somebody mentioned hush uh earlier
too which was the one that came out i
think
right after this if you actually hush
you would probably really like it's kind
of like a survival
i mean it's very simple setup it's like
a deaf woman and she's out at a cabin
like writing a novel or something and
like this dude starts stalking her and
it's like this cat and mouse kind of
game
um that is also very very good like a
really really tense
um you know survival horror kind of
movie and that's also really good
and um i think after that he made before
i wake which is really good that was the
one about
i think we watched that together a while
back i think that was the one about the
kid whose
dreams kind of manifested like in
reality like he would dream about
butterflies and like his parents would
see them like their or the parents that
adopted him
i think it's on netflix now that i'm
thinking about it and like i said he
also did
gerald's game uh stephen king adaptation
a really really good stephen knack
stephen king adaptation which i think is
why he ended up doing dr sleep
but um yeah i mean this is just like
just a great [ __ ] movie and um
just real real creepy like the imagery
is real creepy just a really great
um just a really great concept of
this mirror making you think that you're
doing things
that you're not doing it's a mind
control mirror
yeah and it's like and it's really
freaky because you never know and it's
haunted
yeah like you never know what is
actually happening even at the end
you don't really know what's actually
happening because you could read this
movie
in a way because you know when um
the when the brother tim he gets out of
because he ended up shooting his dad and
it was this whole thing like back in the
back when they were kids when he gets
out of the psychiatric hospital
he's kind of been um
you know he's been through therapy and
the therapist has been able to convince
him
you know the mirror didn't do it you
know what i mean like the mirror is not
supernatural
you just saw it that way because of the
trauma and everything so he's really
bought into that
and the sister who has been out this
whole time and has been
researching how she's gonna destroy this
mirror so it doesn't [ __ ] up someone
else's life the way it [ __ ] up her
family's life
and she's like this mirror is [ __ ]
haunted and we need to do something
about it so there's like this really
great conflict between the two of them
and the great thing about it is that for
a long time
you're not really sure if she maybe is
crazy if maybe there's
nothing wrong with the mirror that maybe
she is delusional about it
and he's actually in the right like he
actually went through therapy and he
figured everything out
and he's like no we just misperceived
things because we were kids and it was
really traumatic
and so we just invented this whole story
so
you know so i really like that they kind
of played off that conflict and for a
long time like she has all this [ __ ] set
up about the mirror and like at first
like nothing happened she's like watch
the plants are gonna die and then they
don't
and all this other kind of stuff you're
like maybe she is nuts maybe she is
remembering it wrong but then [ __ ]
starts going crazy
but the thing about it is that you could
watch the movie as
the mirror is obviously haunted and
cursed
or you could read it as they're both
delusional and they're both see
that's the way they're both seeing
things and it works either way
yeah but that's not what it is though
the mirror is haunted well i think it is
too
yeah but i'm just saying if you wanted
to you could read it as them just being
delusional and that and that totally
works as well she um
did all that research about the history
of the mirror and
had photographic evidence of everything
that happened around that damn thing
and no that was statistically totally
improbable
of everything that happened right yeah
so no it was it was it was bad
it was a [ __ ] haunted mirror and like
i said mind control to kill you yeah i
like it
i like that they didn't like kind of
like the overlook you used mind control
and manipulation to get you to kill
people
and then they were absorbed into the
mirror a bunch of ghosts
and yeah yeah that's actually a good way
of putting it that it was
just kind of like because every time
someone died
by the mirrors you know machinations or
whatever
they kind of became joined in with it
because you know at some points you see
like all the people that died over the
course of the history
of the mirror which had been around
since like 1750 although i think she
says
they don't have any record of it prior
to that so i really like
that its origins are like kind of
shrouded in mystery like you don't know
where it came from and like i said
i mean mike flanagan said that that's
what he liked that because it
just kind of came out of nowhere it
didn't have an origin you don't know
where it came from you don't know why it
does that
um you know it's just it's just bad and
it does she did
dig up photographic evidence of victims
and people who had been killed in
[ __ ] weird-ass ways woman [ __ ]
pounded herself to death with a hammer
that's right yeah
and you know what i mean near that
mirror and it just no
that didn't happen that stuff like that
doesn't happen for normal reasons you
know what i mean
it was paranormal she had
photographic evidence yeah you know she
didn't invent that evidence
so no it it
you could read it either way but that's
not what it was it was
uh that's it was too improbable well
yeah and the thing about it is that when
you're watching a horror movie that has
like a supernatural thing to it it's
kind of obviously a lot more fun to be
like yeah this shit's haunted
it's like supernatural other than you
know no they're just crazy people but
i'm just saying you could read it either
way
and it works either way um yeah louis
said i think hush is on netflix it was
i'm pretty sure that's where i saw it
um and i think some of other uh mike
flanagan's other stuff is on there too
i think before i wake might be on there
and uh
obviously gerald's game is on there um
i don't i don't know about his other
movies like i said absentia is on 2b i'm
pretty sure
um oculus might be on 2b2 if somebody
wants to check i'm not
real sure we'd like i said we got the
blu-ray um that one of our
lovely peeps sent us so that's how we
watched it
but you know uh
let's see terry says tom and jenny did
you like 1974 is the town that dreaded
sundown
yeah i actually do really like that
movie based on the phantom killer case
although there's a lot of stuff that
happens in that movie
that didn't happen in real life it's
pretty close to what really happened but
like the whole thing about the girl
getting killed by
wasn't there the girl that got killed by
like having like a trombone or something
yeah that didn't happen she didn't i
mean she did die but she didn't die like
that
um that was made by charles b
pierce the same guy that made the boggy
creek movies yeah
[Laughter]
and he was in it short shorts oh my god
so
charles b pierce he was in the town that
dreaded sundown i think he was one of
the
you know keystone cops that was that was
the only thing that i would have not
done in that movie was like made the
the funny comic relief cops i think it
really kind of undercut
the creepiness of the rest of the movie
well he did that because of all the damn
ed wood movies had that
yeah that's why he did that i mean you
could have he thought it was supposed to
have comedic relief
i guess it would have it so of course we
gotta have it you know what the [ __ ]
because the movie is so scary that you
have to like put some funny in there so
people will
you know so it can be like a relief
that's what he thought but i think that
was kind of the traditions of the time
i mean you could have incompetent cops
but it just seemed like the cops were
just like a [ __ ]
vaudeville act it was a little over the
top they were in the 50s
yeah that's why you put that in there
charles b
pierce the first okay now i will say the
first boggy creek
was a pretty decent flick yeah
the second or third one that was on
mystery science theater
boggy creek even though it's called
boggy creek 2 and the legend continues
although i think it's actually the third
boggy greek movie if i'm not mistaken
yeah that one was atrocious
but it's hilarious to watch which is the
one that has the legendary dudes sitting
on the porch goes yeah that's my kind of
woman yeah that's boggy creek too in the
legend because
that was we
i think it was a boggy creek too but it
was a completely different movie
okay and then i guess because nobody saw
that one he's like well i'm gonna make
another boggy creek move but i'm gonna
call this one boggy creek too as well
even though it's the third one
so i don't think i ever saw the second
one the second was actually the third
movie
i think so i'm remembering correctly the
one that's called and the legend
continues i'm pretty sure that's the
third one even though it's called boggy
creek that dude was the only good thing
in that movie he was [ __ ] hilarious
that dude's name was jimmy
clem jimmy clam jimmy klim yeah i
remember because
you know i've seen that episode of mst
so many times i mean
just the whole the whole thing about
charles b pierce
being a professor in it and he just has
this [ __ ] funny he's so
condescending yeah and he's just so
like he just has these little shorts and
his little
kind of butt pooches and his like little
stomach is pooching out yeah and he's
trying to
like with some kind of hat on he's he's
he's trying to be like something about a
smokey in the bandit
or something something like that oh and
his real-life son is in it too
trying to make him a movie star and his
real life son is like this really really
skinny
blonde kid and he just is shirtless
throughout pretty much the entire
shirt off which is like so so fun like
when there's no reason for him to be
running around without a shirt on he
just has like the shirt
over his shoulder it's weird [ __ ] man
there's like two kind of 80s style hot
chicks and they're going out and camping
in the woods
well he's got to surround himself with
these 80s styles hot chicks him and his
son out camping with him
him teaching them science yeah
boggy creek science yeah it's like a big
fit of science
it's true [ __ ] funny the girls were
cute though
they were yeah and it was just like your
typical your typical blonde and then
your typical brunette
well no they were both they were both
brunettes they were okay yeah
but they had the feathered hair and the
[ __ ]
dream catcher necklaces [ __ ] looking
like feathers and [ __ ]
quarter flash yeah like [ __ ] from
quarter
[Laughter]
i mean but yeah so the whole part where
they go down the [ __ ]
because it's set in arkansas you know
because that's where that dude is from
yeah
and uh the whole part where they go down
the [ __ ]
river and go to uh crenshaw that's the
name of the character
the big fat hillbilly yeah with uh she
should have just named him jimmy clam
i know that's because that's a perfect
name right or just or just clem they
could have just called him that
but uh because he totally looks like a
clam but he's like so he has no
shirt he just has overalls but the
overalls
he only has one of the things buckled so
it's just like hang so you get some like
nice man-tit there it's very very
attractive
and he has like this big yucky beard and
he's always like chewing tobacco and
spitting
and stuff but he's just i don't i wonder
if that's what he really talks like or
if they just kind of like
uh they were like you know redneck it up
yeah or if he's really like that
maybe they kind of like i think he might
have been i i got the sense that he
wasn't really actually
i think he was hired because that's the
way he was that's kind of woman but yes
a man's coming
and uh the bigger the little one looks
just like the bacon
yeah yeah yeah yeah he was funny i loved
that
and then he had to like dirty himself up
yeah
remember that that was his costume yeah
he just put some dirt
on himself like every [ __ ] and he had
like a rubber band
[Laughter]
over here like if you live in the chat
if you live in a shack
then you're gonna have some dirt on you
yeah and the camera's gonna see it
that's not how it's gonna work out but
you know what i mean it's just it's just
funny
[ __ ] fun i mean if you're going to
watch it i would recommend watching the
mystery science theater episode
because holy [ __ ] they make such good i
mean
i i really really like my favorite
mystery science theater episodes i know
they did a lot of 50s monster movies and
a lot of people like those
but i'm really really into the 70s and
80s movies
and especially ones that are that have
redneck characters
yeah because they like because because
this one
boggy creek 2 and uh the giant spider
invasion which was said in wisconsin
um those were [ __ ] hysterical
like all the [ __ ] that they talked about
they made jokes about
the best one though was the rift tracks
version of [ __ ] manos heads of fate
and bradamic and those i think you can
watch those
on to be actually i know you can the the
uh rifftrax live
burdemic i know is on there i don't know
if manos is on there
we saw that yeah we saw that in the
theater when they first did it
they did solar panels solar panels
that dude that made solar panels
he's made a bunch of other movies what's
that dude's name james
nyan or i can't remember what his name
is but um oh that's the uh
the the filipino guy right yeah or
vietnamese or
i can't remember where he's from but he
doesn't know how people date
he thinks white people just date by
sitting on each other's laps
if you sit on somebody's lap then you're
dating
it's just the weirdest [ __ ] and and from
this
in his opinion you meet girls by seeing
them on the street
following them home and knocking on the
door right i'm like yeah um
do that in real life see how that works
what happens
[Laughter]
and rightly so yeah and then as soon as
you meet the girl she's gonna sit on
your lap
that scene facing you because okay
the the one that we saw because rifftrax
has done a bunch of his movies because
they're kind of like the gift that keeps
on giving
yeah um i can't remember what the name
of it was
but it was like he just saw people date
he saw white people dating when he was
growing up and that's what stuck out to
him is that they sit on your lap
or he just saw something in a movie that
he got over and over again
i mean they're so weird just see her so
you
follow her all the way home two or three
miles home and then knock on her door
says i saw you
on the street two or three minutes she's
like oh okay come in and you know i just
think you're beautiful and
let can i come in you know that's what
he did
i couldn't believe that [ __ ] this that's
not how serial killers tried
i know damn
i know i'd be like i'm calling the
police right now so yeah
you might want to answer that's not how
it's done in the way
[Laughter]
this it's just like i feel like because
that guy and tommy wiseau the guy that
made the room
i think people love those movies so much
just because
the people that made them obviously just
have no idea how real people
talk to one another or act with one
another so it's almost kind of like
it's the closest thing that we'll ever
get to
what it would be like watching an alien
that made a movie about people you know
what i mean
that doesn't have any insight into what
people are really like or what they're
really thinking
so i think that's why people really just
because some of the decisions that he
made are just so
so bizarre yeah yeah it's like he
doesn't know how people work
doesn't know how people work she doesn't
know how cultures work
it's just the idea that
you date somebody because you know that
person
that you have friends in common you know
i mean that's that
i guess that was an alien concept to him
it's written that's kind of like a
creepy
dangerous because i've known some dudes
that probably
thought that that's how it worked like
oh i just see a hot chick walking down
the
street
and i think she's hot so that means that
means i can date her so i have to
because you know who cares what she
wants yeah who cares if she's got a
boyfriend or [ __ ] looking at some
other dude you know
right it's like i think she's beautiful
therefore she owes me
yeah it's kind of like that type of
thing and it just it's weird because it
doesn't come across
it doesn't come across that sinister in
his movies
but it just comes across as more just
completely clueless close to how [ __ ]
works yeah
yeah it's just it's super super weird
and all of
like all of his uh female characters are
all
models that's yeah that's that's the
character
the character model yeah because isn't
one like a victoria's secret model
yeah was that birdemic or maybe that was
the other one i don't remember i don't
remember
he did a weird sci-fi one too that had
like the worst special
effects of all time yeah i guess you
just kept seeing
[ __ ] models model white girls and you
go yeah it's gonna be my movie
models yeah everybody likes models
you're either you're not either model or
i don't like you
you're either a model or you sell solar
panels yeah he sells that's right
there's nothing in between and he has a
really strange
because his other movies have this too
he has a really strange fascination with
real like corporate culture yeah yeah so
he he
thinks that that is happening in a board
room yeah and he and he's like really
into i mean you can tell that he really
really thinks this [ __ ] is super
riveting
yeah even though nobody else on earth
literally thinks well that's kind of the
way it was in a damn
godzilla movie all the important [ __ ]
was happening in some kind of meeting
room
between the government and the military
and the scientists
i feel like the whole movie happened
there so many were cute girls in that
bunch
yeah which that doesn't happen so many
50s horror movies
it's like you know people remember them
for the iconic moments like oh look it's
the giant spider
oh look it's like the big radioactive
turkey or whatever the [ __ ] it is
but it seems like that if you put all
those scenes together it would be like
literally less than five minutes
the rest of it was white dudes standing
around in rooms talking about the
problem
and talking to each other on the phone
that too a lot of that
i mean some other [ __ ] on the
phone yeah
one office to another yeah that the
world runs
in these offices and then you gotta have
it down
a board meeting to talk about the
problem
yeah and talking about the problem
solves it somehow
sure yeah i mean isn't that funny
i just feel like every 50s monster movie
i've ever seen
is 95 yeah dudes in lab coats
talking to each other in an office yeah
and they're explaining to you and to
each other how everything works
oracle says and women screaming and
trying to run away yeah that's right
there's a there's a little bit of that
but women just sit standing there with
something creeping up behind him
touches him on the shoulder like a big
spider leg comes down
my favorite in the turnout my favorite
thing and this is probably
this was in a lot of horror movies even
into the 80s
um where you get like monster or killer
or whatever
running at the female victim and she
just kind of stood there
yeah you saw that a lot in
jollo movies like the killer would bust
in the door and the door is like way the
[ __ ] over there like in that
and i get you're scared i get it some
people freeze and stuff but like
seriously
girl it's like she's just kind of
backing against the wall i'm like look
there's a door over there there's a door
it's like get a weapon do something like
don't just stand there it's like oh no
here he comes very very slowly and i'm
soon going to be heard
or the man and woman are running from
the villain the villain grabs the man
they start fighting and the woman
stands there and just watches the fight
happen scream she's like huh help
we were thinking don't even get the gun
get the gun
hand me the knife none of that [ __ ] she
just stands there [ __ ] do
something we were laughing about that
because we've been re-watching the um
the logan's run tv series yeah and there
was one out of that there was a lot of
that in there was
like one part where logan and he was
fighting with who was he fighting with
francis i guess
yeah him and francis were right there on
the ground and jessica is just kind of
standing there going huh
yeah she wasn't doing a goddammit
yeah he's like you know you could help
why don't you like jump on his head or
something i mean something
kick him in the balls
[Laughter]
punch his balls just help me i mean
there's two of us
yeah i don't really get it it wasn't
feminine to get involved in a fight even
though
even though even though your destiny
hung in the balance
between who won well i'll leave it up to
these men to fight it out
[ __ ] that i'm getting i'm getting in
there i'm mixing up with that [ __ ] yeah
at least hand to do the gun i know
please do something else you can't just
like stand there for yourself
i don't want to mess up my hair that was
70s television but i think it was just
kind of a
cultural holdover from 50s horror movies
i think when and probably even before
going back to the 20s and the 30s
yeah where a woman was just tied to the
track screaming
yeah tried to train you know tie her up
to the train tracks and just scream and
that's her role in the movie yeah they
wouldn't even really try to like do
anything to free themselves yeah
wouldn't even try to roll off the tracks
they're just like oh well
yeah well he put me on a train tracks i
guess there's nothing i can do about it
until some dude comes and saves me
yeah because i'm completely helpless
that was theater yeah theater i know it
wasn't supposed to be it's just it
wouldn't fly nowadays obviously because
everybody'd be like [ __ ] why are you
just standing there
it was like little kids playing yeah it
wasn't
her just being on tracks was supposed to
scare you you knew you didn't really
want her off the tracks and then the
[ __ ] story be over
yeah you know it's like we want to kind
of see we have to let this guy come and
save her
yeah yeah it's all hokey [ __ ]
i just i was reminded of it again
because when we were watching logan's
run and i just thought it was funny that
she was just kind of
standing there watching him fighting
going huh look at look at him go
logan's run series was actually the
television series was
a lot better than i remembered it it's
written a lot of the writers were the
same writers from
star trek the original series yeah i
mean william f nolan did a lot of the
yeah because he's kind of big in the
sci-fi it is it does have some tired
tropes like they're redoing
most dangerous game and they're doing
things like with
illusions you know what i mean like
aliens that can control what you see
but and it's all pretty telegraphed you
know what i mean you know
what trick they're playing on you so but
i guess that was just the way television
was back then i mean you were you were
kind of in on the joke
if you were watching it um
other than that production values were
okay
it's kind of fun to watch um
it's kind of like just a relaxing yeah
okay who's that
okay it wasn't my appointment was it no
it was a 904 number
that was that's jacksonville all right
so uh
yeah it's just kind of fun to go back
and watch my old television
you can really see the beginnings of
star trek the next generation
because the android rem is definitely
the inspiration for data
yeah like that's that's data it's that
same damn character almost
pretty much um you know by the time you
know it and really when in the big
picture it was only a few years later
that next generation started to come out
you had logan's run the television
series
it had a lot of the guys that had that
were behind star trek the original
series
but then star wars came out and the
[ __ ] bottom fell out of [ __ ]
logan's run that wasn't cool anymore
so the the whole they got rid of [ __ ]
the logan's run television series
and they actually started [ __ ] coming
up with something called star trek phase
2 which they were going to bring star
trek back
but it got rebooted in to start into the
first movie star trek the motion picture
and a lot of the cast that was going to
be in
star trek phase 2 and a lot of the
writers ended up being
in the movie of of the motion picture
but then that cast basically got taken
out because they
they wanted to get the original cast
back in into the movies
um but a lot of the [ __ ] that they were
doing behind the scenes with the sets
and the story writing and
getting the guys together for star trek
phase two
and to a certain extent motion picture
they they were starting to work on
they knew they wanted to bring the
television series back
and they were already working on things
i saw the sets and the designs man it
looked a lot like star trek the next
generation
yeah so they were coming up with it way
back in the late 70s
yeah i mean next generation you never
really saw next generation i've seen
some of it
some of it yeah yeah the first couple
seasons were
hit and miss but by the time season
three was around it was pretty solid
it got better as it went yeah oracle
said i'd kind of like see a reboot of
the logan's run tv series
but i think you'd have to have them find
sanctuary at the end of season one
and then the next season is about how
sanctuary isn't what they thought it was
yeah that's actually a good idea i would
watch that yeah
and um pat asked where you could find
the logan's run series
we actually bought it on dvd i mean it's
on dvd right i got it on dvd and it's
not even on blu-ray three dvds in a set
it's kind of hard to get hold of it's a
little obscure it's obscure and
it's real good quality the first episode
is the pilot and it's about two hours
long and it's really like the best one
and it shows a lot of clips from inside
the city of domes and
it sets it up pretty well um
we just went on to season on the disc
two again
and we're just starting to get into it
it did have some pretty good
um pretty good concepts and it did kind
of break some molds like
there's one episode where
they they find a place that they think
is sanctuary but it turns out it's too
everything that they want seems to
happen and
their robot ram is like or you know the
android rem is like
he ends up in there and he's going like
no this is all an illusion
you know i guess it's kind of like a
holodeck he could see it but it's an
illusion
and it turns out that really where they
are is they're in an alien spacecraft
that that can kind of uh make illusions
and inside that spacecraft this
spacecraft is going around collecting
male and female pairs or two pairs of
all these aliens from
all these different planets try to find
their weaknesses so they can come back
and invade them
and uh it's pretty cool [ __ ] rem
tries to lie his way through it
tell him that he's a human that he's not
an android and that
humans are inferior to him and that he's
the dominant species it's pretty cool
but what kind of the what kind of broke
the trope is is that a lot of the aliens
on the in
on the ship or these cells they were
pretty ugly
um but it turns out they were the good
guys they were all
like good people the aliens
that are trying to capture everybody all
look like pretty people but they're
illusions too
so it's kind of don't judge this book by
its color
by its cover and fun fact the the female
alien the pretty one
yeah that was the same woman that was in
giant spider invasion yeah
that played the disgusting dude's wife
also can we talk about
in the pilot i think that they told them
not to do this afterward because i think
only in the pilot they did it
every time they said robot they said
robot robot yeah
it's a robot like they didn't know how
to say the word
oh we just like kept well like i said
it's really funny because i saw some
sci-fi from the 50s and 60s where they
said robot
like they've you know put the emphasis
on the second syllable which i thought
was a little strange
but in this one in the pilot everybody
was saying
robots yeah and i'm like did she just
say robot
yeah she said robot so just we just like
we just ran
that i definitely just ran with his
whole entire thing
then they're influencing each other
i guess it wasn't a common word about in
california
i was like robots oh my god now what was
good about the series though
is that you find out that um they
borrowed some stuff from the books
evidently
turns out not everybody [ __ ] died at
30. some people cheated
and there was a secret council in charge
of the city they were all people in
their 50s and 60s
a bunch of old things yeah and they were
making deals with people running the
[ __ ] that if they [ __ ] did special
[ __ ] that [ __ ] they could be in part
of the council and live longer
and then they're like yeah but you're
killing my people and like yeah but we
have to it's an enclosed system
and it's an enclosed system and we can't
have the overpopulation then we can't
people [ __ ] and breeding like rabbits
in here you know or or we'll all starve
so that was kind of the idea of what it
what what was going on
but um it's pretty so far seen it again
i liked it the first time i saw the
series
seen it again i kind of see how
experimental it was
um it has shitty props you know what i
mean
but they weren't shitty compared to star
trek the original series
yeah you know but i mean you could tell
some of them were toys they bought
somewhere and like changed up a little
bit the interior
decorations and designs of the of the
places the sets and the locations they
used were good
um cute girls and [ __ ] skimpy outfits
pretty much do the whole thing well
everybody's like sign me up
yeah everything's everything everything
looks like some kind of [ __ ]
1970s swinger motel
everything i'm pretty sure some of those
sets were actually
70 swingers motels yeah i mean yeah at
least that one where they were in the
mud baths or whatever yeah
it looked like speaker hotels i'm pretty
sure that's what that was
like i love motels that's it [ __ ]
chandeliers and [ __ ] weird [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
two side-by-side tubes yeah like the
[ __ ] shag carpeting
shag carpet you're there it's a
fake fake a [ __ ] stone
walls inside the interiors with fake
[ __ ] waterfalls and [ __ ] happening
inside
the underground base with chandeliers
hanging and 70s chandeliers and shag
carpets and robots servant girls and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah and the robot servant
girl's name was siri
that's right yeah so you know somebody
who somebody saw that
and i was kind of like i wonder if that
if that's where they got the idea sure
it was for actual theory yeah it was
we were kind of wondering about that i
was like that'd be a deep cut if whoever
came up with the concept
probably you could probably get the set
if you can't stream it
you could probably get that set for
about twenty dollars oracle said you
could pay
and watch it on amazon prime okay or
voodoo
yeah it's worth it yeah how much they
want for it you know
yeah i mean if you like the movie uh the
original movie or if you liked the book
you would probably be into it like i
said it's you know it's got some 70s
cheesiness to it but it's kind of fun
and complicated
so did the movie yeah that's true it was
this the same tone as the movie
um